pendant près d'une heure 46 hier soir
sur tf1 le président de la république
est resté branché sur la nouvelle image
qu'il veut donner de lui aux français il
faudra attendre la sortie des sondages
pour savoir si justement ces français
ont collé à cette image
en attendant les premières mesures nous
montre que vous avez été nombreux à
suivre ce show télévisé ordonné par un
des plus grands maîtres du genre yves
mourousi notre confrère de la maison
d'en face s'est livré au petit jeu des
questions réponses des souvenirs et des
clips ainsi que des bons mots une
méthode nouvelle dans le genre à
laquelle s'est plié avec constance un
certain talent le président de la
république qu'il faut le dire est plus
un habitué des bibliothèques que des
petits écrans vidéo
le président et mourousi ont donc parlé
de tout pendant 100 minutes au cours de
cette conversation à bâtons rompus et
dans un décor très in quelques petites
phrases politiques bien senti à
commencer par la fameuse cohabitation en
cas de victoire de l'opposition 86 le
président restera à l'elysée sait c'est
que la constitution mais ne prévoit
aucunement que les députés élus à
l'assemblée nationale puisse censurer le
président la république
alors tous ceux qui parlent parce qu'ils
ont un gros appétit se précipite vers ce
qu'il croit être un fromage je leur dis
c'est pas la peine de s'expliquer
davantage
c'est non la clé sous le paillasson je
ne connaissais pas pas mon genre on sait
aussi que renault ne sera pas
dénationaliser que le président aimerait
voir se développer les tuques qu'il y
aura une centaine de télévision locale
et qu'enfin la france n'est pas du tout
chaude pour participer au projet de
guerre des étoiles du président reagan
voilà pour la politique au sens convenu
du terme
revenons-en à l'image maintenant mais
après tout ce numéro entre guillemets
n'était il pas monter pour signifier que
les deux sont indissociables de cette
image qui se veut nouvelle voici ce que
nous avons retenu
vous savez ce que c'est que c'est bon
pour ce même mois quand j'étais enfant
dudevant en inverser l'ordre des
syllabes dans le no1 pas très nouveau ca
d'autres puisque ça veut dire branches
et bien entendu je veux pas faire
mal informés mais c'est déjà un peu
dépassé un loyer du dircab les c'est
craignos ça se comprend mouawad moins
bien je ne sais pas
signification ça veut dire peur ou ça
veut dire c'est moche connaissent pas
c'est pas terrible et c'est l'enfer
c'est en faire ce bout de l'enfer sur un
mois désirable concernant robert la vie
de président non non non non non pas du
tout cela étant si c'est difficile si
c'est l'enfer sa vie dure c'est
difficile
seul enfermé si ça veut dire divine
comédie non